the economy saw no growth in February
but what does that mean and why is it a
problem
[Music]
February
because of industrial action in the
public sector Teachers Health Care
workers and civil servants all walked
out weighing heavily on public sector
output
if the overall size of the economy isn't
growing that means our incomes are
unlikely to rise in Britain we're also
suffering from high inflation which
means our living standards are
plummeting economists believe we're in
line for the biggest drop in disposable
incomes since the 1950s
[Music]
growth can also put pressure on public
services because it means that tax
revenues also grow more slowly this
forces the government to either cut
services or to increase borrowing